era un po che non facevo video correlati
vero ragazzi let's go back into è bella
tutti ragazzi
l'ultima volta avevo fatto un video
correlati un po particolare oggi ne
avete letto nei consigli della roba
forse questo sarà il migliore episodi di
video correlati adesso vediamo allora
ragazzi oggi abbiamo ben quattro
ricerche da fare molto molto difficili
quindi sono quattro sono poche ma
saranno belle cazzute partiamo da questa
da silvio berlusconi a animal crossing
vabbé
[Musica]
allora perché da silvio berlusconi ecco
qua il buon silvio perfetto
io non so come poter arrivare a animal
crossing da silvio berlusconi però
partiamo a silvio berlusconi lei allora
da quello proviamo ad andare su dove
cariche a chi ha fatto animal crossing
tv crossing in generale
allora animal crossing vabbè gameplay io
non l'ho mai portato sul mio canale
allora abbiamo già hicks murri e denny
lazzarin capisco cosa con centri con
berlusconi però ok vediamo se lo scavo
che già già già demi lazzarini e hicks
muri ti portano nel mondo gameplay con
hicks murri quindi forse meglio se click
to hell on earth
adesso mi escono tutti i palestrati del
mondo e non me ne frega più una sega non
riesco più andare avanti seguendo tutti
benvenuti ai miei stessi io peso come il
suo braccio alla ex moglie ha smesso di
fare che impiega un sacco di tempo
quindi non so come arrivare il gameplay
semi spuntasse il canale di qualche
tecnica con step di arrivare il gameplay
teoricamente ci mettiamo in atto infatti
siano reati a fort spero iddio che non
mi pensi solo four nights e mi stanno
mostrando solo forme cav h litterio
famiglie però il problema chi non ho mai
portate come posso trovare una rotazione
di monique rossi il ragga nintendo
diventare nel canalino intendo devo
entrare su nintendo in qualche modo
perché animal crossing è uscito da poco
quando si registra nostro video mi hanno
bloccato tutti in banca spettare a
questo super mario ranno che super smash
bros
allora allora allora sono entrati in un
ciclo di miei video però ci siamo siamo
nell'angolo nintendo mario odyssey siamo
nell'altro nintendo wii teoricamente
dovrebbe uscire fuori guarda c'è anche
pokémon dai potrebbe uscir fuori
direttamente animal crossing a uscire
almeno il canale nintendo perché dal
canale di nintendo teoricamente dovrà
arrivare dimostrò fin sperando iddio
nintendo switch deciso chi avere
assolutamente ti devi che cercherà d
allora è giusto è giusto siamo nel
giusto
i tre titoli più giocati no alle classi
ecco perché proprio lui e da silvio
berlusconi a animal crossing ragazzi
quando volete
questo questo io non ho idea di come
iniziare però vabbè d'appello figo
corona vyrus a barbara d'urso contro
vittorio sgarbi
[Musica]
allora non era d'urso ci credo che culo
la partenza è live non è la d'urso non
era d'urso va bene la partenza subito
dopo il video iniziale ok non ragazzi e
ho trovato già gianna d'urso è già
sgarbi incredibile forse forse lo trovo
subito fermi un attimo per partita to
ciao vittorio ragazzi record sono un
cazzo no io no io non vado musica per le
mie orecchie capo musica è già anche
questo ci sia tolta allora il prossimo è
un po particolare perché da il godzilla
al godo come un riccio
[Musica]
come arrivo a godo come un riccio
cercherei sempre di andare da barbara
giusto perché la d'urso l'aveva
intervistato vi ricordano teoricamente
poi non so non mi copro male io qui se
io arrivo dalla tua che arrivare dalla
d'urso da godzilla e è sempre un po dio
le luci sulle stesse e ora io non ci ha
salvato il culo che niente a posto
next speriamo di uscire presto dal caso
della di lion non si sa come uscire
aiuto mai contro tenno ipantellas non
stanno mai fatto qualcosa con la d'urso
però già ci stiamo uniti ma già ci
stiamo allontanando abbastanza se mi
spunta se per qualche strano motivo la
di un gusto qualcosa dell'igiene sarebbe
incredibile aldo giovanni e giacomo miei
ragazzi questo è veramente un altro
possa arrivare a non lo so ci sono
subito di altre c'è quindi è già co
driver e la loro intervista eccola qua
perfetto per i veri vedi però vedi però
pomeriggio 5 però e mediaset quindi
arrivare a momenti a 7 dalla rai
porco demonio pero per i beni che sono
già è già in testa ci avevo la il
percorso e quindi se riuscissi a beccare
con alcun appiglio non poteva andare a
andato anch'io a che tempo che fa
maledizione scarpe o qualche biondo
chiama fermi fermi qua ho trovato watt
il biondo chiama attenzione fermi tutti
fermi tutti fermi tutti fermi ecco ciao
sono proprio io
che godo come un riccio in questo
momento ho spaccato il joystick in
studio perché mi è caduto però volevo
risultare il risultato chi se ne frega
ragazzi siamo all'ultimo che è molto
difficile dire signori da fegato grasso
a martin garrigues
[Musica]
non solo arrivare a martin garis partire
da questo presupposto io ho fatto un
video con martin galaxy a2 quindi potrei
e potrei arrivarci
confavi j però lui è più sul piano
musicale ovviamente quindi magari non so
se dico di andare su di me o sulla
musica devo fare una scelta e devo farla
adesso di me ci sono tanti video quindi
non so quando andrea dinka fa musica
adesso devo entrare nella nel repertorio
mondiale le canzoni quindi non solo
quelle buco non solo quelle italiane
però dai io ho scelto la via musicale
che forse la più difficile non lo so
provvediamo tutte canzoni italiane
vogliamo uscire la sta roba per favore
grazie a gabry ponte
gabry ponte siamo già dj attenzione
guarda che io già un traguardo ed ha
fregato da fegato a capri ponte armin
van buuren frega dimitri vegas elenca
attenzione attenzione ragazzi subito
simona basta che cerco basta basta
signori da fegato grasso amarti garics
atti ma anche perché quando vuoi vedere
martin garics ci sono i corpi il payback
è un casino
quello che vi sia piaciuto iscriviti al
canale e ci vediamo in un prossimo
episodio e non ci vediamo come sempre ad
un prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]